welcome back to the Daily Grind everyone
I want to show you guys how amazing
these cabbages
look and in fact some of these napas are
starting
to kind of form that Center um kind of
dense area uh like they do so pretty
soon I'll have those but um these Bok
chys are looking really good and the the
mini Bo Cho are definitely ready I'm
going to make a stew right now so I got
to harvest a
few so I just put a knife down
cut off the stem leave the roots in the
ground just like so let get off as much
dirt off as possible look at that what
an amazing baby bok
choy these are really doing well and
then also in this bed I had or have some
peas but they haven't started forming
any uh any flowers yet on this one
excuse the uh the plane over top once I
can Harvest all these I'm going to
replant these bok choy probably in the
next couple days um I am going to
harvest quite a few right now and maybe
tomorrow the next day get some for a
stir fry so I'm pretty excited about
this this is one of my favorite times of
year because these are some of my
favorite veggies to grow you can see how
well they grow here so well thanks for
watching everyone I will see you guys on
the next video If you guys like this
kind of content Please Subscribe hit
that Bell notification for future video
updates also if you could hit the like
button would really help me in the
channel out I will see you on the next
video now you guys Tred to escape the
Daily Grind